what happens when a copy of a video game  and a usb drive of manga are placed in  scp-914 dr teori selected a copy of the  elder scrolls 5 skyrim and a usb drive  containing the entirety of the manga  jojo's bizarre adventure part 5 vento  oreo for testing first the video game  was placed in on the setting one to one  the output produced was a copy of the  elder scrolls 4 oblivion next the usb  drive was placed inside on the setting  fine the output was one usb drive  containing an animated adaptation of  jojo's bizarre adventure part 5 vento  oreo with english subtitles years before  the real adaptation came out dr teori  elected to keep the new usb drive for  herself for research purposes only of  course